[Music]
you've been so hilarious on Arrested
Development
your character is constantly flashing
her breasts yeah so yeah and how that
maybe has carried over into your
personal life well I'll tell you it's
been great and really fun it's super fun
when you're walking down the street and
random people come up to you and you
know pretend to flash you and scream
like say goodbye the days and that kind
of thing
my only it's kind of a bummer though
most people don't actually flash me and
I'm kind of wishing they would bake free
they pretend yeah they're like we're
like oh and I'm like let's see what you
got come on be it one time in from the
French Quarter when I was there I got
actually flash but like who doesn't in
the French Quarter I didn't feel that
special but yeah if you want to flash me
go for it and if you're a lady and I'm
with my husband then definitely go for
it cuz I always feel like it might be
nice for him to see some new boobs you
know
[Applause]
that's such a nice generous statement
that's for your husband Boober II wrong
with that now you are you mentioned that
you're married you had an unusual
wedding theme
I say winking at our theme which was the
Planet of the Apes let's just stop there
for a second
some people have you know sunrise
rebirth spring that's kind of cheesy you
went with or you know French
you know French Riviera you went with
Planet of the Apes yeah never heard
anybody do that
well I'm sure someone's done it I mean
we can't be the first but it wasn't I
don't like it wasn't like a full Planet
of the Apes wedding but we had during
the cocktail hour we had a like the
movie screens the TV screens in the bar
we had the movies playing we had Ryze
playing on one screen and then original
obviously Planet of the Apes playing on
the bigger screen right which was great
we had I surprised my husband and bought
this really beautiful off of Etsy you
know a porcelain cake topper that
instead of a bride and groom was it a
chimp bride and groom we you saw that on
the cake all your guests to chimps at
the top yeah yeah and then I bought them
as a wedding present I guess you're
supposed to buy a present for your
husband anyway so I didn't know about
that true yeah sorry
what do you mean you're supposed to buy
a present for your husband like you you
buy a present for your new no no I think
you are right yes I think you're correct
well I I got zip oh you got nothing
there's still time you can renew your
vows maybe yeah okay now okay I'm sorry
I thought I was gonna hate my guts no no
no no no no but she better cough up
maybe when you guys got married that
wasn't a thing
[Applause]
very modern development yes it was 1951
you see we were both virgins because
[Applause]
know somebody I want to show you the old
black-and-white footage of my wedding
there we are coming up in the middle row
Sekar the present I got my husband is
that I got him a vintage Rolex watch and
and I had it engraved like you do but I
engraved it ape shall not kill age he
would know I really loved him like if I
just felt like I love you or our
initials or the date that we got married
he'd be like yeah it shall not kill ya
but but he did tell me later that I got
it wrong but ape shall never kill ape
but the guy I mean the guy when I took
it to the engraver was like you're crazy
you're gonna engrave a Rolex with this
and it's barely gonna fit no one's ever
gonna be able to read it maybe that's
why my husband needs reading glasses now
anyway
that's but how fantastic so many guys
were in love with you right now because
we all idolized that movie it's a good
one yeah there's so many quotes I would
have gone with from that movie
yeah that's your stinking paws off me
you damn dirty ape that's that's what I
sound like that sounds like a wedding
night yeah